CLIFF: Good afternoon, everyone.
Today for the Google Talks,
the Talks at Google program,
we are very thrilled
to be talking
about absolute value, what
really influences customers
in the age of nearly
perfect information.
Today we're taking an in depth
look at behavioral decision
making and consumer choice.
Guiding us through
this talk will
be Professor Itamar
Simonson and Emanuel Rosen.
Itamar is actually a professor
at the Stanford Graduate
School of Business and one
of the most influential
and cited researchers in
the area of decision making
and marketing.
And he's discovered some
of the phenomenon, himself,
described in various journals
including the compromise
effect.
And we're also joined
by Emanuel Rosen,
the author of the national best
seller, "The Anatomy of Buzz",
a pioneering book that
predicted the rise
of interpersonal
influence in marketing.
And his research appears in
numerous journals as well.
And so we will have time
for some Q&A at the end.
Please use the microphones.
But without further ado,
we'll launch right in.
So thank you very much.
Please join me in
welcoming them to Google.
ITAMAR SIMONSON: Thank you,
and thanks for your patience.
Today we would like to talk
about consumer decision making
in the age of nearly
perfect information.
But before we get there,
let's take a moment
to talk about what we used
to believe about consumers.
In the beginning, the assumption
was that consumers are
generally rational, but because
they cannot tell the quality
of things, marketers
can influence them using
advertising, and branding,
and building loyalty,
and all those other things
that you might have read
in marketing textbooks.
Then about 30 years ago, it
got a little more interesting.
And more and more
studies that we have done
have shown that
consumers often make
decisions that are irrational.
By irrational, contrary to the
common concept or conception
of irrationality, what
we mean by irrationality
is that we violate
assumptions of economics.
People do not maximize utility.
And sometimes they
choose a over b.
Other times they
choose b over a,
even though it's
the same a and b.
I spent the first 20, 25
years of my career working
on the irrationality
of consumers.
This is an article that
I published back in 1994
in the New York Times, and I
think the title of the article
tells you what it was about and
who I thought was in control.
Let me just give you
a couple of examples
of effects,
irrationality effects.
So in this particular
study, we showed one group
of consumers those
two microwave ovens.
We asked them to make a choice.
You see there is one that's the
Amazon that's less expensive,
and a Panasonic
that's more expensive.
Both of them are 35%
off the regular price.
A second group of
consumers chose
among three microwave ovens.
You note that the top one is
the same one that we saw before.
The bottom one is the same
one that we saw before.
But now there's a third option,
which is another Panasonic.
It's even more expensive,
has more features,
but it's only 10% off.
OK.
What did we find?
We found that
consumers were more
likely to choose the Panasonic
over the Amazon in this group
than in the other group,
even though we added
another Panasonic
to the choices.
That's known as the
asymmetric dominance effect,
because this Panasonic is
dominated by this Panasonic.
Since then, those effects
have been shown many times.
Now a year ago, a doctoral
student at Stanford,
[INAUDIBLE] and I,
tried to replicate
the asymmetric dominance effect,
except that, in this case,
we provided consumers,
or participants
in the study,
additional information.
The kind of information
that you receive today
when you go to shop on
Google Shopping, or Amazon,
or any other website.
We showed them some reviews.
We showed them other options.
We showed them more detailed
specifications, and so on.
So some people chose between
these two paper shredders,
and other respondents saw
these three shredders.
And you don't see here all
the information they received.
As I said, they received a
great deal more information.
What did we find?
We found that now, the
asymmetric dominance effect
was gone.
Consumers no longer
made a choice
on the basis of comparing
the options in front of them.
Instead, they took advantage
of all the other information
we presented to them.
As we will explain later,
we would connect it
to a broader phenomenon
whereby consumers are much less
likely to make judgment relative
to the options you show them
and relative to all
kinds of other things,
like other products
by the same brand.
And instead, they evaluate
each product individually.
So this is a really fundamental
change in decision making.
Let me give you another example.
This is something to do
with frequency programs.
This is based on a study that
Ran Kivetz, who at the time
was a doctoral
student at Stanford
and is now a professor
of marketing at Columbia.
So we looked here at whether
participants-- they didn't even
know they were
participating in a study--
would sign up for
this loyalty program.
So we told them-- these
were students at Columbia--
we said, if you
join this program,
after you buy twelve sandwiches
in any food place on campus,
at the end of the day you'll
get two free movie tickets.
A second group of
participants were
told that if they buy 12
sandwiches and they also
by 12 orders of sushi, they
will, at the end of the day,
get two free movie tickets.
Now, which program
is more attractive?
The first one.
This one requires you to
buy 12 sandwiches and also
12 orders of sushi
for the same reward.
Now we asked all
of the participants
about the kinds of food
they like and dislike
so we could identify
the segments
of what we called sushi lovers.
For those, what
we found was they
were more likely to join this
program than the other program.
Why?
We call that the idiosyncratic
[? futuristic. ?] What
we're saying is that people
really cannot assess the value
of a program or how you
translate effort to reward.
Instead what they do,
they assess the reward
relative to the
effort that it would
require from other participants.
And they say to themselves,
I really like sushi.
I buy sushi anyway.
Relative to others this
is more attractive for me.
And as a result, those
people who like sushi
were more likely to prefer
the frequency program that
required you to buy both
12 sandwiches and 12
orders of sushi.
That's another example
of making decisions
relative to other
things, in this case,
relative to other consumers.
This is, what Cliff mentioned,
the compromise effect.
So what I worked
on many years ago,
about 30 years ago
for my dissertation,
I looked at what I later
called the compromise effect.
So some participants in
the study, in this case,
chose between two cameras.
That's actually from a
study done later in 1990.
And you see there are two
models of Minolta, which
those if you who
are old remember
there was such a brand, and
different number of features
and different price level.
Other people choose
among three cameras.
You know that the first two
are the same as those before,
but now there is another one
that has even more features
and is more expensive.
Well, what did we find?
We found that most consumers
shifted to the middle option.
The big loser was
the cheapest option.
And there was a general tendency
of people to go, to converge,
on the middle option
in a given set.
Again this relative
decision making.
Why?
Because it means that you
are not basing your decision
on the quality and value
of the particular option.
Instead, you're looking
at other options.
And on that basis you
make your decision.
Again, last year we tried
to replicate this effect,
and we used again cameras,
different cameras, same design.
And as I said earlier, we
provided more information.
We also gave them reviews, and
we got them specifications,
and additional information,
the kind of information
you easily obtain today.
The compromise effect was gone.
Now the significance
of this effect
goes far beyond the compromise
effect and the other effects
that I talked about.
It means that there is a general
trend that Emanuel and I are
calling the shift from relative
to absolute decision making.
If you think about it, suppose
you were buying a laptop back
in '99.
You might have based your
decision on the brand,
on where it was made.
You might have used
some general rule,
such as you get
what you pay for.
These are all relative
proxies or quality proxies.
Why?
Because you compare
this product that you're
thinking of buying to other
products by the same brand,
other products of the same
price level, and other products
in the same country
of origin, and so on.
You're not making your decision
on the basis of your evaluation
of the quality of this
particular product.
Now the problem
with quality proxies
is that they're
often inaccurate,
because some brands make good
products and bad products.
And that's true for all kinds
of other quality proxies.
Now what has changed?
These are just a few of
the sources of information
that you have today to
assess the real value
of each individual product.
It means that today
you don't have
to rely on relative proxies.
Instead, you can evaluate
each product individually.
Now this is a very
important change.
If you think about if you've
ever taken a marketing course
or read any marketing
textbook, you
know that much of what
we teach in marketing
is about the creation of quality
proxies, how to build brands,
how to create customer
loyalty, all of those things
that represent quality proxies,
or relative quality proxies.
And we say that they are
becoming, in many product
categories, much less important.
Now let's simplify
and talk about what
are the main forces
that influence
consumer decision making.
One, we call O. O stands for
what you learn from others.
For example, a friend
of yours tells you
about a good restaurant
or a good movie, that
would be an example of O.
P is what's in your head
from prior experience,
what you were born with,
your family background,
what you've done before,
anything already
stored in your head.
We call that P, or prior.
And the third one is M, which
is the influence of marketers,
advertising, brands, and so on.
These three sources
of information
together influence what you know
and how you evaluate products.
If you want a summary of what
has happened in the past 10,
15 years, it's the rise
in the impact of O,
through reviews, with the
easy access to expert reviews,
social media, and so on.
At the expense, primarily,
of marketers, of M.
Because if you can assess
the quality of each product
individually, you're
less likely to rely
on what marketers are telling
you about the product.
And as we know, they
have their own interest
to promote those products.
So one thing to
think about it, is
what we call the O continuum.
And what we're saying is
that the degree to which O
influences consumer decisions
is a function of the product
category.
So there are some products--
before you buy a Snickers bar
or before you buy paper
clips, you probably
are not going to
bother to read reviews.
On the other hand,
before you buy cameras
you may very well will.
It also varies by segment.
Some consumers are
more likely to look
for reviews than others.
It also depends on context.
If you buy a product on
a website like Amazon,
like it or not, you'll
be staring at reviews,
so therefore they are
likely to influence you.
So there are different factors
that determine the impact of O
on your decisions.
The rest of our talk will
focus on this end, which
is all of those categories and
situations where consumers make
decisions largely based on
O, on what others are saying,
consumers and experts.
Well now quickly we'll review
some of the key marketing
mantras, or the key
marketing principles, that
are influenced by
this shift from
relative to absolute
decision making.
Let's start with branding.
And there's probably nothing
more marketing than branding.
And this is the
topic where we are
saying all kinds of
surprising things in the book,
among other things, this
notion that consumers
are becoming a
little more rational.
Even though nowadays there's
a lot more talk about consumer
irrationality there's
really nothing
that generated greater
response then this notion
that brands in many
product categories
are becoming less
important, especially as
indicators of quality.
Some people, in fact are
saying that, if anything,
brands are becoming
more important.
Why?
They say, well there's
so much information
out there on the
internet that consumers
experience information overload.
And as a result, what they have
to do, they just go by brand.
This argument assumes
that consumers
have just two options.
Either you process all
the information out there,
or you go by brands.
Of course, in reality,
there are a lot
of good intermediate solutions.
You don't have to process
all the information.
In fact, you can make
very good decisions
and get a great deal of
information in a few seconds.
And I'll illustrate
that in a second.
Let's think about restaurants.
In the past, chain restaurants
had a significant advantage,
because you knew what you were
getting regardless of location,
even if, for example,
you were out of town.
However, think about
nowadays if you're
looking for information
about individual restaurants.
This particular
one is a restaurant
from Seattle, Machiavelli.
If you're interested
in Machiavelli,
you get over 400 reviews.
You get over 50 pictures,
photos of various dishes.
You have a great
deal of information.
It doesn't take a
whole lot of effort
to get an idea of how good and
how popular this restaurant is.
And if you like to read a
little bit of the reviews,
you quickly see that
one of the issues
there is that there
are long lines
and they don't
take reservations.
So as we can see,
this new environment
increases the power of
independent restaurants
at the expense of
chain restaurants.
Indeed, a study conducted
might by Michael Luca
established that's the case.
That as Yelp penetrated the
Seattle market, the revenues
of independent
restaurants increased
at the expense of
chain restaurants.
Now this has far
reaching implications.
For example, it means
that the entry barriers
to many categories
are declining.
As long as you have
a good product,
you have a chance
of being successful.
Think about this
computer that we
brought here and
didn't work by Asus.
EMANUEL ROSEN: It did work.
ITAMAR SIMONSON: It did work.
EMANUEL ROSEN: Yeah.
ITAMAR SIMONSON: I take it back.
Asus used to make components
for other PC manufacturers,
but at some point
their CEO decided
to sell directly to consumers
under the name of Asus.
People told him, you're
not going to be successful,
because no one knows
your name, and you'll
need to spend a lot of
money on advertising.
But he thought that he has a
way of doing it successfully.
He just sold a good product
that got excellent reviews
on the internet.
Some of you may
remember the Eee PC.
And indeed, it became
very successful.
And nowadays Asus
is in the top five
in categories such as
laptops and tablets.
It also means that
previously unknown names
can establish themselves
as leaders in the category.
You may be familiar with the
recent acquisition of Google
called Nest, and
some of you are also
familiar with Roku, which
is one of the leaders
in the video streaming category.
Previously unknown names
have become very popular.
It shows you that when
brands are less important,
and each product is evaluated
independently, then even
no-names have a chance of
establishing themselves,
as long as they have
the right product that
gets the right reviews.
It also means that it's
easier to diversify.
Now in the past, we used
to teach our MBA students
that each brand is associated
with certain perceived skills,
so therefore, you should stay
in your area of expertise.
But that's no longer true,
because if each product is
evaluated
independently, it means
that you can be in all kinds of
categories like LG and Samsung.
And as long as you make
the right products,
consumers will accept it.
EMANUEL ROSEN: Hi.
I'll continue with the rest
of the ideas that are still
very common among marketers.
Itamar talked about the
first one, which is brand
is the most important thing.
Another big one is loyalty.
Talk to marketers and they
say that nurturing loyalty is
the most important thing, is the
best investment you can make.
Marketers love to
talk about loyalty,
promote loyalty,
measure loyalty.
But we're saying that when
consumers can actually
assess the quality of
each individual product,
loyalty is becoming
less important.
Let me tell you about my
experience in buying cars
throughout the '80s and '90s.
So in 1985 I was a student.
I got this old car.
I was trying to
remember how old it was,
but it was really
old, from my uncle.
And I started
driving this Volvo.
Now in 1989, I was going to
buy a new car, or another car.
The most dominant piece
of information in my mind
was my past experience
with that Volvo.
So guess what I bought?
I bought a Volvo.
In 1995, the same
thing happened.
I bought a Volvo.
In 2000, I bought
a Volvo, and so on.
In 2012, I bought a new
car, and it was truly
a different experience.
I remember it very vividly.
I was sitting in
front of my computer,
cars.com, edmunds.com,
reviews from users,
reviews from experts, videos.
Actually, I remember one
video-- so I was still
considering Volvo.
It's not that I hate Volvo--
but I was looking at the video
off a backup camera.
You know when you put it in
reverse, you want to see.
And that's a feature that
I always wanted to have.
And I remember how
slowly-- I don't
know if anyone here has a Volvo,
or that particular Volvo--
the screen for the
backup camera was coming
up so slowly that
I was saying, no.
I'm not going to do that every
time that I put it in reverse,
and I will have to wait
for the car to back up.
So suddenly, the way I
was buying this car--
I was actually assessing
what it would feel like,
what it would be like to
actually drive a Volvo, as
opposed to relying on
some past experience.
So loyalty is going to
be less of an issue.
Marketers can rely
less on loyalty,
which means your
success is determined
by your current product.
The good news is
that your competitors
suffer from the
same thing, which
means that your competitive
advantage here and there can
be improved.
That's not new, but
as loyalty goes down,
it's even more powerful.
Measuring loyalty--
and there are
lots of organizations
that put a lot of emphasis
on measuring loyalty--
is less informative.
Because the consumer can
tell you that they're loyal,
but when they go to
make the decision,
they are not going to rely
on their past experience,
but they will rely on O.
The third mantra, which Itamar
essentially addressed already,
but I just want to mention
again, is irrationality.
So in general, marketers and
certainly people in academia
believe that consumers
are irrational,
and that you can manipulate
quote unquote "their action",
by using the context of
offer, or the framing.
Again what we're saying is, no.
It's going to be less true
as consumers can assess
the value of each product
as Itamar just showed you.
Number four is the big one--
and this is four out of six,
so we're almost reaching Q&A,
so think about your questions--
communication.
Communication is a big area, and
there are several mantras here
but I've combined them under
positioning, brand awareness,
persuasion are key.
Still marketers by and large,
if you open a textbook,
they tell you that if you
persuade, if you position it
rightly, target it rightly,
you will be successful.
Again we're saying, no.
It's going to depend much
more on the absolute value
of the product.
That is determined by O.
So let's look at something
that is called positioning.
What's the idea
behind positioning?
The idea is that,
if you're a company,
you look for that area that has
not been occupied previously
by your competitors, and you
try to associate your product
with that.
So Volvo stood for safety,
Cadillac stood for luxury,
and so on.
Which makes a lot
of sense, but this
doesn't work as
well when consumers
base their decisions on reviews.
Let's look at an
example with phones.
In the past three
or four years there
have been several attempts to
position the Facebook phone.
So the idea was, nobody
has the Facebook phone,
so HTC and AT&T,
I think, came up
with this idea of associating
the product with Facebook.
Maybe it's a great
idea, but the problem
is that reviewers hardly
ever review a product only
on one feature, especially
not the feature you
decided they should
review it on.
So I read a lot of reviews of
this phone, a lot of reviews,
and I don't remember
maybe a handful that
talked specifically a lot
about this feature of Facebook.
Of course everyone
mentioned it, but they also
talked about the screen,
the keyboard, voice.
They talk about the phone.
So it's much more difficult
to position a product the way
you want consumers
to think about it.
Or more in general talking
about communication,
persuasion is becoming
much less important.
There is almost
no point in trying
to persuade your customer
that your product is better,
because they go to O for that.
That's O's job.
They will read
reviews and determine
if your product is
better than others.
So what is your job?
Your job is to promote
an ongoing flow--
your job as a
marketer-- is to promote
an ongoing flow off authentic
content from real users,
from experts, and so on.
Another concept
in communication--
when I worked in advertising,
it was all about awareness.
You want to make the consumer
have Sony, Sony, Sony,
Sony at the top of
their mind, so when
they reach the
point of purchase,
they'll grab the first
Sony product they see.
But again, you
understand that when
the consumer comes to
a point of purchase
and actually decides on reviews,
this is much less relevant.
It's not about creating
that top of mind awareness.
It's about generating
interest in specific products.
And this translates to
very practical things.
Do you go and buy banner
ads that just say Sony?
Or do you create a
PR campaign, invest
in a PR campaign, that promotes
the latest product that
does this or that?
And we talked already
about positioning
that worked when people relied
on M. Much more difficult when
people rely on O. There's
another mantra, or a set
of mantras, in the area
of market research.
Overall, marketers believe
that market research
can predict people's choices.
Well, it's less
true when consumers
rely on O, because
here's the problem.
Market research,
by and large, tries
to predict what
people's preferences are
at point a in time.
So I ask you a lot
of questions, and I
try to understand what
are your preferences.
The problem is that at
point b in time, you
will no longer make the decision
based on your preferences,
but you will actually reach
out to O for that information.
Let me give you an example.
A 2007 study, conducted before
the release of the iPhone,
concluded that such
convergent products are not
desired by US consumers.
That was a mega study
done all over the world,
and they determined
the iPhone will not
be desired by US consumers.
As we know, this did not happen.
The opposite happened.
What was the problem?
What was the problem here?
The problem was that
they measured P. People's
preferences at point a in time,
where consumers were actually
influenced by O, that
is reviews, TV coverage.
I remember David Pogue wrote
about it in the New York Times,
such an amazing review.
All this stuff is the stuff
that actually influences people.
So what we see in market
research-- what we already
see and we predict will become
even more true-- a shift
from predicting what
customers will do,
to actually tracking
what are we saying.
Because think about it.
If O influences the
decision, go directly to O,
and see what O is saying.
Because this is going to
ultimately determine what
the consumer will do.
There will be more
systematic measurement
of O and real time experiments,
adjustment and experiments,
much more in real
time then trying
to predict what people will do
six months from now or a year
from now.
Because again, they are
influenced by other sources.
The last set of
mantras is in the area
of diffusion of innovations.
And this, I wouldn't
say that it's
a mantra that is shared by the
whole tech sector, for example.
I think that there are many
companies that don't really
operate that way.
I suspect that Google
is one of them,
but let's not get into that.
But there are a lot of
people in high tech marketing
who still believe that you
start with the early adopters,
and then you try to get
into the early majority
by addressing different niches.
So I'm sure you're familiar
with categories of adopters.
There are the innovators,
early adopters, early majority,
late majority, et cetera.
Well this type of
thinking-- which
was initiated by Everett
Rogers, the author of "Diffusion
of Innovations", who I still
consider him personally
my mentor.
And he also was a great
supporter of my first book
that Cliff mentioned.
And it's also reflective
work of a very good book
called "Crossing the
Chasm" by Geoffrey Moore.
I see that some people
are familiar with that.
--But this way of thinking
was really true in a world
where one thing existed,
and that is uncertainty.
Think about it.
The moment that
people can actually
assess the absolute
value of things.
They know what
they're getting into.
Uncertainty is
resolved much faster.
So there is much less of a
need for category thinking,
and less of a need
for a strategy
where you say, OK in order to
move to the early majority,
I am going to
identify some niches
and get into these niches.
And if you look-- we don't
have time to get into this,
but if you read it
in the book-- we
talk about how the
iPad was introduced
versus how the tablet
PC, back in 2000,
was introduced by Microsoft.
Two different approaches.
The iPad obviously
was more successful.
And one reason, we
believe, is that they
let consumer niches
and different groups
adopt it by themselves
without dictating
which niche should buy
it according to them.
So that was a very
quick overview
of the different mantras.
We talked about branding,
what Itamar talked about,
loyalty, irrationality,
communication, market research,
and diffusion of innovations.
And more broadly, what we
talked about in this talk--
and then we'll move to Q&A-- we
talked about really a new era
in consumer decision
making and marketing.
Itamar described this shift,
that we believe exists,
from assessing from relative
thinking-- it's good
because it's from this
brand, or from this country,
or it costs so much-- to
assessing the absolute value.
And what happens when
this is the case?
Proxies for quality
play a much smaller role
in O dependent areas.
Again, the value
is determined by O.
What's left for
the marketer to do?
Don't fire your
marketing department yet,
because marketing
is still important.
Marketers have to
generate interest.
They have to make sure there
is an ongoing flow of O.
And probably most
important, they
need to track O, analyze O, and
make sure there are adjustments
to provide the best products
a company can provide.
Thank you very much, and
we'll take it now for Q&A.
MICHELLE: Hi.
My name is Michelle.
I'm on the search
marketing team.
So my job is to make sure that
folks who have a smartphone
choose to search with Google,
hopefully through our app.
And so, the point of
sale for us-- and this
is a very important
moment for Google
in terms of point
of sale-- is not
buying something with a review.
Maybe you even
already have the app,
or maybe you even have
a choice of browsers,
or maybe you're on your
computer and you can open Google
or you can open Bing.
One of the things
that we look at
is how do we make sure
that the user chooses us
at a moment when
there is no review,
there is no purchase process.
We're actually past that point.
So we sometimes
rely on the thinking
of defaults, which I'm sure
you know of Dan Ariely's work.
And we think about
how do we get the user
to put this thing in
their tray, if we're
talking about an iPhone.
So I was wondering if you
could talk about these concepts
and how they relate
to a decision
where you don't have
that information anymore.
And you make that
decision very quickly,
and it's one of the
most important decisions
that consumers make for Google.
ITAMAR SIMONSON: You talked
about defaults and status quo,
which research on that has been
done for a long, long time,
and that's certainly true.
But as you said, usually you
have, at any point in time,
you have whatever comes up.
Is it Google, or Bing,
or Yahoo slash Bing.
And that's what you use.
Now the decision that you make,
it really largely depends on
what comes with your computer,
or what you set as the default.
It's not the kind of decision
that you would evaluate reviews
each time.
Now there might be
some differences.
Now Google search, if
I recall correctly,
has an advantage over
Bing in the sense
that you get the results even
before you finish the search
term, which I think
Bing does not offer.
But Bing has better
social media integration.
So that may be a
factor that influences
your choice of a search engine.
I don't think that what we said
about reviews would apply here.
I'm not even sure that
that's a matter of reviews.
Let's not forget.
Search engine is something that
you use, how many times a day?
Many.
Every day.
So that's a very different
kind of decision.
Not something like a camera
or lots of other decisions.
It's a decision that
you make all the time.
You set a default and
that will determine
what you decide to do.
Now it could be, over
time, that you figure out
there is another search engine
that has certain advantages.
And that may, over time, cause
you to change your choice.
But it's a different
kind of decision,
a very unique one,
an interesting one.
As you said, what's the default?
And it's a slow
changing decision.
So if, over time, you
see someone else is using
another search engine and
they seem to be happy,
that may cause you
to change your mind.
It's not the traditional
O environment.
You know brand and loyalty
can mean different things.
We know loyalty could be
just a matter of habit.
I fly United, because they
have the most flights from SFO.
I may like them
or not like them.
I fly United.
Then there is
loyalty that's kind
of more emotional attachment.
I don't think-- I use
Google all the time-- I
don't think I'm emotionally
attached to Google.
I think it's not that
kind of category.
And therefore,
building the brand-- I
think it has some value.
I think a limited value.
It just so happens that Google's
search engine is really good.
And if you've been
using it, you'll
continue to use it unless you
have a really good reason not
to.
But I think it's more a matter
of performance, real quality,
and less of brand
equity in the abstract.
AUDIENCE: In the
teaser for this talk
it was mentioned
that your thesis is
that fake reviews,
or spam reviews,
are not a problem long term.
Could you elaborate
on that please?
EMANUEL ROSEN: First
of all, we think
that numbers make a difference.
That if you have four or
five reviews of something
it's much easier to manipulate
through fake reviews.
Fake reviews are not
going to disappear.
There is always
going to be attempts
to manipulate, to
game the system.
But overall, when you
remember this restaurant
that Itamar showed,
Machiavelli in Seattle,
they had 440 reviews, I think.
Extremely difficult to fake
that without getting caught.
So, we believe that
as numbers grow,
the credibility of reviews
as a source will grow.
The hosts of these systems,
for example in this case Yelp,
have a very strong
economic incentive
to make sure that they
curve manipulation.
The reason is very simple.
Yelp makes its money
through advertising.
If you stop trusting Yelp,
because you have repeated
experiences where you read
reviews of great restaurants
and you go there
and it's terrible,
you will trust Yelp
less, which will
mean that you won't go
to Yelp next time, which
means Yelp will not
be able to be viable.
We think that people may
switch to another source
of information.
But let me tell you which
source it will not be.
It will not be the marketer.
It won't be M as the source
for information about quality.
And it's not that marketers
are perceived necessarily
as crooks or dishonest.
It's simply because the
marketer, by definition,
has vested interests.
So you look for alternative
sources of information.
10, 15 years ago those
were very limited.
What we experienced
in the past 10,
15 years is an explosion
in the availability of O,
and this is not going away.
So you may see movement
within O. People
will stop trusting one
source of information
and will move to another.
For example, if people
in general stop trusting
reviews from strangers they
may go to trusting something
like graph search, Facebook
graph search, where
you can tell who that person is.
Currently, there are no
signs that people are not
trusting reviews.
In fact, there is evidence
that people definitely
trust reviews.
And the reason, I
believe, is simple.
Overall reviews do reflect
the general concept
of a place, a general
idea about the product.
Is it 100% accurate?
Absolutely not,
but you get an idea
of what your likely
experience is
going to be when
you read reviews.
AUDIENCE: I used to work
in the games industry,
and one of the
factors that we always
faced with introducing
new consoles
is a lot of parents
would always--
they played Nintendo
games when they grew up--
so they would automatically buy
then Zelda, and Super Mario,
and 3DS, and Wii, and whatnot.
So the dominance of O over P,
I don't see that all the time.
Actually in business
to business commerce
it's almost always P, as well
as some O and other factors.
ITAMAR SIMONSON: So you
have kind of two questions.
Let's talk about video games.
It's clearly very O dominated.
I mean if your
friends like a game,
and if Xbox is more
cool than PlayStation
whatever it is now 4 or 5, that
will certainly influence you.
It may be reviews, not
necessarily on Amazon,
but social media, just the
old fashioned word of mouth.
So that certainly has been
for a long time an O domain,
much more so than
a marketing domain.
As to b-to-b, that's an
interesting question.
Because it is true that as
absolute value goes b-to-b--
let's say if you invest millions
of dollars in something,
you probably have consultants,
and you have in-house experts,
and so on.
You could assess absolute
value even before that.
Now, one thing where
the b-to-b sector
is lagging behind
the consumer segment
is that you don't have all
that many review sites.
Let's say in
enterprise software,
you're beginning to see
some websites, relatively
small numbers.
And they tend to be
overwhelmingly positive,
which makes them a
little less useful.
We would expect that
there will be development
also in the b-to-b
arena with respect
to their reliance on reviews.
But they're beginning
from a higher level
where, especially
for large purchases,
they already have a pretty good
assessment of absolute value.
AUDIENCE: So going
back to the first point
where, if I bought something
and I really liked it--
It is a very high bias.
I mean, you bought Volvo
four times over the years
until you changed your mind.
And if the O reinforces the P,
it becomes almost automatic.
It's by default.
I'm going to buy this thing
that I've already tried.
ITAMAR SIMONSON: Well, if you
heard good things about skim
milk, and you started
buying skim milk, yeah.
That becomes a
habitual purchase.
That's what you're buying.
You're not even
thinking about it.
Many purchases, especially
more substantial ones,
are not decisions that
you make every day.
So when the time comes to buy
even a new electric toothbrush,
you may check reviews.
In other words, for
less frequent decisions
that tend to be the
more costly ones,
that's where you see
the biggest shift.
AUDIENCE: You have
mentioned that the marketers
traditionally were trying to
influence consumers directly
by creating a brand,
by targeting products
for specific niches.
And since, there is
a trend for consumers
to evaluate the
value of each project
individually rather than
relative to other products.
So you have mentioned
that the role of marketers
will be to observe
the trends in O,
and then to make sure
that the company responds
to those trends.
So my question is
this, is it foreseeable
that marketers would draw a
different lesson from this?
And the lesson
would be to attempt
to influence O rather
than consumers directly?
And if so, what
do you think would
be the effect on the
whole review system?
ITAMAR SIMONSON:
Let's not forget,
marketers have to come
up with good ideas.
So it obviously would not
be sufficient to introduce
products, see what customers
are saying, and then revise it.
As Emanuel said,
market research,
asking consumers what they
will want in the future,
often doesn't work.
For truly new concepts
it probably never did.
But you need to come up
with the right products
and then be responsive.
Did you--
EMANUEL ROSEN: Yeah.
What I would like
to add-- part of it
is the answer I gave this
gentleman here about marketers.
Some marketers will
try to influence
O in unethical ways, that
is, fake reviews, et cetera.
So that's one part.
Another part is very legitimate.
That is, I think that
indeed PR, for example,
is becoming more important.
Because you can see PR
as a company's attempt
to promote its point of view
to O. The O that matter,
that is, expert reviews.
The experts-- and that's
not a new thing of course,
but it's becoming even
more important today
when people rely so
heavily on expert reviews,
and accessing these
resources is so easy.
So a company that
introduces a new gadget.
Today it's even more
important than 10 years ago,
even five years ago, to make
sure that people who matter,
the Engadgets of the world
and the tens of thousands
of these bloggers, and
so on, know about it.
And you cannot ultimately
influence what they will say,
I would argue.
Of course you can
here and there,
but overall these
people, this part of O,
reaches a broad consensus
about a product, which
is another interesting thing.
But of course trying to
influence O in legitimate ways
will be important,
and also trying
to make sure that there is an
ongoing flow from current users
is another important thing.
Because if I go to a restaurant,
or I consider a restaurant,
and the last review
was written in 2009,
I'm probably not going
to go there, right?
So you need to make sure it's
always viable and has energy.
AUDIENCE: I don't know.
A company could spend
a lot of resources
trying to get, say
90% of all bloggers
to write about, to review,
their product first.
Let's say there are two
competing companies trying
to enter a certain market,
and Company A, let's say,
could try to basically pay
money to all the bloggers
to influence their
product first.
It's not that they would
write fake reviews.
They would write real
reviews, but they
would write them first.
So what people
see, mostly, would
be reviews for product
of the Company A.
Now it's not illegitimate, but
it certainly would probably
influence what choices
consumers will make.
EMANUEL ROSEN: In
theory-- Oh, I'm sorry--
AUDIENCE: So yes.
So the question is does changing
the domain where marketers
try to create an influence
from consumers directly to O,
do you think that benefits
the consumers overall?
Does it make things
more objective?
EMANUEL ROSEN: I
understand the question.
Overall, there is one
thing that bloggers really
want to have more
than anything else.
You know what it is?
Readers.
So if I start feeling that this
blogger is basically giving me
the party line, and are
really not giving me
the true story-- Most
bloggers, if they
know that there is a product
and another product will come
shortly after it, the
first thing they'll do,
they'll compare them.
I mean bloggers want to give
their followers-- they want
to have followers first of all--
and in order to have followers,
they need to provide them
with valuable information.
Again, the same thing that
I said about fake reviews.
Yes, people will fake, will
game the system sometimes.
It's far from being perfect.
The same applies to the
blogosphere as to reviews.
But overall, I believe
that the system does work,
and blogs' reviews about
products or about services
overall reflect the actual
experience of consumers.
When they don't, people
will go elsewhere,
because if they're
disappointed they
will not trust this
source anymore.
Same logic works here.
ITAMAR SIMONSON: You've
been waiting patiently.
AUDIENCE: OK.
I have something quick.
Do you see any difference
on amateur reviews
like Yelp versus professional
reviews like Engadget,
how they affect consumers?
ITAMAR SIMONSON:
I think that they
tend to talk about different
things in many cases.
Let's say that I'm thinking
of buying new headphones.
I'm interested in how
comfortable they are.
I think for that,
I probably would
go to-- if I see 100
reviews, I probably
will look for user reviews.
On the other hand, if you
talk about some technical
specifications and comparing
this model to that model,
I may rely more on
Engadget or CNET and so on.
At the same time,
there is some overlap.
And I think it's
not a zero sum game.
You can, and consumers
as we know, they do both.
They go to expert reviews,
and they go to user reviews.
It's very easy to do.
CLIFF: Thank you
all for stopping by,
and we'll be able
to sign some books.